I don't even like Cary caramel get out
of here right I agree but they're good
car know what to do unless you're in
Snickers get wait you're you're in
Snickers all right I'll allow it where
else are you get out of here I can only
be Italian talking about food
dude
Runk
hello
hello hello
hello hello okay cool what is up hello
everyone hello everyone welcome to
Lifeline it's episode
85 all right it's Sunday November 26th I
personally I don't know about Chris but
I personally hope you all had a
beautiful
lovely memorable Thanksgiving oh yeah
it's been Thanksgiving that's right yeah
and you know what for Thanksgiving you
should be thankful for everything in
your life and and sign up for Lifeline
luxury thankful for everything in your
life you know and so because you're
thankful for everything in your life you
are thankful for Lifeline luxury being a
thing that is real that you can sign up
for go to
patreon.com Lifeline luxury see my
special grow or die it's available it's
Sunday night what else you going to do
besides watch this go to Chris lea.com
and get grow or diey now streaming only
on chia.com my fifth special and it's uh
and yeah that's what's up so I'll be in
Trenton Phil Adelphia reading Oxnard
California Brea I will be in Sacramento
I will be in El Paso Phoenix and
Albuquerque go to chris.com to get
tickets you know what I today
interviewed someone who saw someone so
bad so far burned to death uh in front
of his eyes lit himself on fire and burn
to death you know how I heard that story
on my upcoming podcast called the
private record it's not a comedy I
interview people with really wild
stories some of them are really funny
yeah
some of them are about witnessing other
humans burn alive uh so you got a crazy
story doesn't have to be that crazy but
crazy according to you submit yourself
as a potential guest to the private
record at the
private.com find us on Instagram Tik Tok
baby baby and sign us sign up on YouTube
get all the alerts subscribe at the
private
record uh go to watch lifeline.com you
get merch and you can send us a message
and all that stuff and send a submission
anyway
what's up guys what's going on what's up
what's up what's up Anthony Anthony so
we have a thing with Anthony uh he
doesn't say hi no no no yes I do Mako
didn't say hi he doesn't say hi loud no
I know we're going to get to that but
generally Anthony doesn't say hi and
when he does like today he doesn't do it
loud enough so I I thought you said I
don't say hi you started to when I got
mad at you yeah but it's like dude you
care about people enough to care enough
to say hi yeah but also it doesn't
matter to say hi really honestly it's
not it doesn't it's not that it matters
it's not like important information you
put away it's just what people do to
acknowledge one another's presence when
someone walks into a room full of people
they know and none of them look up or
say [__] you feel like a [__]
ghost yeah you know say hi to people say
hi to you though you did okay fine you
did you did it too quiet is what he's
saying you did it too quiet which is
basically worse than not doing it at all
you do it to quiet why so well it's the
same thing as not saying at all you know
yeah it's like tried but you didn't
really try so you might as well not I
walked in and Mako didn't say [__] to me
well there you go that's worst that's
the worst thing you can do and and we
walked in and by the way the monitor we
use to talk to people is just on the
ground and and mess it's actually the TV
is all dented up well it's just smashed
and and and and I thought that Maka
comes here every day and he's like man I
haven't been here in a few days you're
saying he doesn't work that hard well no
I'm not saying that I'm just saying
we're it's not it's not
uh and something's not adding up you
know he says he comes here every day all
right and then this is fallen and he's
like well I don't know I haven't been
here in a few days so which is it yeah
what is it
well start lying here we go clear to
throw I haven't been here in a few days
uh I didn't say hello today um a dog all
of these things are true on the stand on
the stand I guess I'm I'm not really
sure yeah here we go taking it real
serious I like it yep what I need to say
at this point oh okay well sorry about
the hello I usually do I'm very tired
that's okay man you're in you're I don't
care I'm just pointing it out sounds
sounds like you
do you're right you're right soundes but
I know usually do I don't care at all
I'm mister I don't care about that he
doesn't care about that I care about
that yeah I think it's
pretty I don't think you should care
about that so some you walk into a room
it's like me Mom Dad Chris and Anthony
are there we're all hanging out
Kristen's there you walk in and no one
even looks up Mom and Dad this
this situation is different Su you walk
just go Su that's something but I do do
that every time I come in I do that what
I'm saying is if someone didn't if no
one that did even sup then what you'd be
like what happened well you would get
upset because you'd walk in and say sup
and I wouldn't say anything that's even
worse of course that's the only thing I
would do I would walk in and say up but
I'm when I'm already in and someone
comes in and say say up I don't know in
this situation I don't need to say a up
we're g to have a whole conversation we
what yeah glad you all and this is work
for people so I'm glad you all agree
that it's good to be disrespectful no
and shitty that's great that's we're
saying that's great that you all decided
that and that I'm the lone wolf with
respect for other human beings it's fine
I'm sorry but look uh you know it is
what it is honestly and it's okay and we
don't even need to talk about it all
that much but we did already so my you
know I couldn't get my I couldn't get
Calvin's toys the right way he wanted
and he said No No No you're ruining you
ruined my life you yep 100% you and you
know what you deserve it you deserve
every bit of every exp I eat it all up
though cuz it's so cute dude oh it's so
cute oh God what is it going to be cute
though when he's like 15 and you need
him to do a thing and he's
like I bit my lip and you didn't well
that was in the restaurant call the
ambulance that was in the Tha restaurant
where I choked a little bit okay when I
was younger I said I bit my lip nobody
said [__] and I said doesn't anybody
love me because what the [__] is going
on I bit my lip and nobody said anything
and that's crazy here's what happened we
were at min's kitchen no no no no that's
a that's the choking one the bite my lip
was in New Jersey oh the bite my lip was
in New Jersey chok the choke okay the
choking one that one was horrendous bite
my lip one okay I get it that one was
horrendous nobody cares about me this is
how it went at min's kitchen though you
choked on rice or whatever I did I
almost died and he choked and he was so
dramatic he got up and left the stepped
out of the restaurant right then finally
obviously because he wasn't going to die
and we all knew that we waited for him
to come back he went he came back he sat
down and the first thing he said was
doesn't anybody love me because we
didn't come outside no and do something
I guess but why then you tell us stand
by that but by way that's not what
happened what happened was I almost
choked I go and I go like that oh my God
I almost choked mom dad you uhhuh I go
don't don't you guys love me what the
[__] and then I go outside that doesn't
sound that much B oh you went outside
after
let off some steam yeah that's even
worse no it's honestly the best way to
do it and it's honestly so [__] up
that nobody said anything I almost
choked well guess what Kristen almost
choked once I cried so how you feel
about that because you had to do the him
lick and she almost
died she almost died that's why you felt
choked up I don't like talking about
that you you brought it up first of all
I don't like talk and second of all you
were fine dude and if for a second you
seemed in Jeopardy even a little bit you
think mom would have just been doing
nothing there's no way Mom worries about
like if it's under 60° and you don't
have two two extra thick layers on you
know she would have [__] panicked you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah but you just
had we don't want you to die cold yeah
yeah no but you were obviously fine
everybody knew you were fine it was all
good then you felt better and then you
said don't you guys love me and then we
laughed and then you walked outside the
Laughing thing was [__] Bonkers it
was hilarious though I know you guys
love me but why don't you act like it
when I'm almost dying is the thing I'm
almost it wasn't even close to dying
that's not even it's funny anyway even
if you did almost die if you recover and
the first thing you say is why does
doesn't anybody here love me that's
funnyit a little bit because nobody said
anything about me almost dying nobody
said anything about how I choked if
somebody said oh my God I just choked be
like oh my god well are you okay like
yeah oh okay I love you you know I love
you in that moment wow but you still
wouldn't say hi to somebody cool all
right I see I see what's up uh I don't
think you would have done that in this
situation if you were looking at someone
across the table doing what you were
doing you wouldn't have been like oh my
God you almost died if they you would
have died laughing cuz you'd be like oh
my God he wasn't cuz you guys just I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm you got oh my God I'm
almost choked I'm not you didn't say
[__] dude I don't I don't think I said
anything yeah you didn't yeah no I mean
why you think I went outside anyway I
went outside for that comment you think
handled it right if somebody in your
family almost chokes you say something I
agree but you didn't almost choke we
were all there looking at you and you
didn't almost choke you went
like that's not even close to alarming
that's what someone does when they cough
well you know you coughed didn't seem
bled hey guys I almost choked I choked a
little bit I couldn't breathe you
guys and then I go outside with no
jacket on it Mom cares about that yeah
she was probably worried that you were
going going to get oh he's going to
catch a chill catch a chill yeah all
right look here's the deal I I think
that I'm past that and it's all good and
but it is a
landmark thing in our in our life in our
family it was immediately a touchstone
event yes Touchstone exactly in our in
our lives and it is what it is but it's
okay but that's that's you know that's
cool and me and my mom still talk about
it and laugh so it's all good well
whatever you guys laugh at me all the
time and it's fine it's why I'm so such
a thick skin and I'm a comedian you know
sleeper okay I was the guy guy it was
forged it was forged you know what I
mean it was forged my my my destiny was
forged that's a good word yeah yeah so
it's just I couldn't couldn't even help
it of course I'm going to be a comedian
are you kidding me it was Forge because
we because we laugh you don't love me
when ioke you God goes oh he didn't love
me chokes oh comedian yeah you you don't
chokes well you're going be comedian you
like that sing it so fast no one Jesus
is the micro Machin guy well I'll tell
you dude I go you know I have a bunch of
new material I have an hour of new
material by the way if you're going to
see my special you can see it and you
still come can see me can come see me on
you know in Phoenix or whatever and I
will be doing new [__] and I talk a lot
about Mom and Dad and I also talk about
other things do you talk about
me actually no not even once okay did I
talk about you ever in I never talked
about you on stage huh one time I I
don't remember it was a long time ago
you said
something I don't but not special but no
but
never me I think I'm talking about like
mentioning me or something on stage yeah
I've talked about I've talked to you
I've talked about you on stage before
but not in a special is what I mean yeah
yeah yeah okay cool all right well
anyway okay I'm sorry dude please don't
stick me up uh all right um are we going
to be able to see the things no yeah
okay guess okay here we
go what's up Lifeline my name is
Gabrielle um so I have a
question for my mom's birthday I got her
football tickets to go see the Seahawks
and the Rams okay it was going to be in
LA and we're going to go together for
her birthday we're both big football
fans and my mom
forgot she made other plans oh my god
wow that's me
so I'm going by myself damn but my
question is do I have to get her another
gift no no way you out of your like I
got her tickets to go see the game for
her birthday right she
forgot do I get another gift um or are
we like it's a good bad child it's a
good question why why you say bad
childhood because she feels like I don't
know let me know I see what do you think
yeah I said B because she thinks she
might the solution might be getting her
another gift when in reality she was
[__] dissed hard by her own mother
dude so nice to get tickets to really
also that's expensive dude any NFL game
there's so few of them that the tickets
are really expensive and obviously
that's not like the reason but that's a
reason why it's even more big go by
yourself it's not like we're going to go
to a movie on Sunday nights got tiet
it's like a big big event go by
yourself uh take pictures videos send it
to your mom and and and and then if she
says why didn't you get anything for my
birthday be like I I did you have the
videos I was there you didn't come it
was disappointing for me hey and you're
a bad mom and you're bad mom for that
you're a bad mom yeah
that's pretty tough stuff she's not a
bad mom I just I mean I have no idea if
she's a bad mom or not but but yeah that
is a that that you definitely do not
have to buy her anything else you're
saying bad childhood because she feels
guilty like maybe she should yeah like
she like she still needs to do more even
though she got her an amazing gift also
it was going to be them going to
something together true it's like it's
not just that we don't know why she what
we don't know what else she booked
though the mom could have been like hey
you know my friend really wanted to go
to this I totally forgot you you do this
a lot in the pis Oh you mean look at all
the angles is what's but you're making
up
angles it's good to look at all the
angles that you're given you don't make
up angles we don't know we don't know
what we don't know dude making up angles
dude we're making angles we're not
necessarily making up angles we're just
saying there's a whole world out there
something else could have happened that
we have no idea why you don't do that
because if you bring up one thing you
might as well bring up every other
possible variable that might exist you
got to look at different variables
though you got to look at different
ideas you know what I said is not
completely crazy it's not like aliens
came aliens could have came down
abducted her mom and said don't go I
disagree down to my fiery core why the
molten thing inside my body that's like
rotating and keeping me alive that's not
a
thing you actually don't have
that uh in the movie about me I do right
so but it was yeah that's deep deep down
in the core of me I dis that's where I
disagree with everything you're putting
for right now but but dude I'm coming up
with with variables that are very
possible you're not think that one's
that possible or or even material it's
like what could have give me an example
of something that could have been more
important than that supersedes that my
friend's dying of cancer and she I
forgot she wanted to go see Selen Dion
and Selen Dion also has a disease and
she's only has a residency in Vegas for
who knows how much longer and she got
him on that day I didn't think about it
I'm sorry I have a question didn't she
say her mom forgot yeah but that is
forgetting in a way but that it it it if
it was that I don't think she would be
calling like you know it's obviously not
that extreme but I'm just saying no dude
I I think you don't know you don't know
this person could have so much [__] pent
up about her mom and she could be like
oh she forgot when in actuality of
course you're right yes we got out of
that one we don't know that that is the
case so why talk about it her mom might
be a parakeet you ever think about that
no dude that's ridiculous know but it's
just as ridiculous to assume assume
anything about anybody else that's not
in the [__] video telling us what
happened sorry
forgot uh all right I think you don't
owe her yeah anything well we agree
about 100% about the solution but we
arrived there in a different way you
don't if anything you have you have the
right to be like hey Mom what happened
like how what ask her how that could
possibly happen that hurt your feelings
or even don't bring up your hurt your
feelings even if it did just be like
what what happened mom so get an answer
fing weird and confusing and shitty yeah
definitely definitely invite someone
else you'll get somebody to go to this
[__] M she said Seahawks game right
Seahawks and the Rams yeah in La
Seahawks and the Rams come on Seahawks
and the Rams yeah don't see smash the
football uh actually don't have to buy a
gift for like three years yeah that's
true that's such oh you think it adds to
yeah it might add a year it might add a
year well because you remember last year
what I did was it you could do it like
that remember two years ago when I got
the thing all right why didn't you get
me anything this year honey well here
I'll tell you because I got you
something real nice real expensive real
thoughtful real sweet yep and guess what
you did with it you wiped your ass with
it so you get nothing this year you get
nothing next year you get nothing next
year maybe in four years I'll consider
it all right all right well yeah I think
that's great good one way to kick off no
pun intended but way to kick off wow the
lifeline cool hey man Chris so I have an
advice question
um to keep it short I asked my boyfriend
for basically like a mushy love letter
with all his feelings in it for my
birthday um that's all I asked for
that's all I got for my birthday but I
just
learned that he didn't write this letter
he copied it verbatim from chai
BT like he didn't get pointers he didn't
get like advice or like ideas from chai
gbt like he copied it word for a word
good job and I'm really frustrated about
this and I don't really know what to do
so I figured I'd ask you guys for
help okay I'm going to you're going to
be mad go first but here's what happened
I got a great he he told her he did this
he's an
idiot how the [__] would she know he
told her yeah well if you're going to do
it just do it but then you know what
dude I got tell you something funny the
guy's an idiot God God or maybe is it
possible I'm going to be you here for a
second is it possible that she was like
this doesn't sound like you and he was
like felt pressured and he
confessed right that's probably more
likely right if she was like what is
that's so vague like what what is you
don't talk like this I think more what's
more likely is he's dumb and he was like
well he's [__] dumb you say to do
that and is to be a guy who's like this
huh when he's faced with adversity a guy
who does that when he's faced with
adversity he goes like go huh okay
totally now here's the thing I don't
know if he's a shitty boyfriend but
that's what a shitty boyfriend would do
CH gbt it yes like dude if you're in
love with
someone does do you understand how easy
it is yeah to write something sweet
especially for her birthday dude come
you already love them that's like the
whole thing all you have to do is write
pours out of you dude even if it doesn't
it doesn't take long to excavate it it's
there open up your laptop and put your
hand on there let your fingers do the
dancing man I mean seriously love should
pour out of you man think about it in
your heart just go like this don't even
look and let your fingers do the dancing
I mean that might not work exactly the
way
that's but dude it's so e like it's so
easy don't go to chat GPD for easy he
did that to see if he could get away
with it dude well then then he's a bad
boyfriend right go okay so then he's a
bad boyfriend so as far as advice I
don't know but let me tell you a little
story about something happened to me
going end in tears yeah it is actually
okay so I and what's interesting is that
someone who is I'll decide what's
interesting after the story not related
to the story directly but in the orbit
of the story someone is in this room oh
okay okay say so it's either me or Mako
correct but so in I believe it's not me
I believe fourth e either fourth or
fifth grade but I believe it was fourth
grade I didn't know you back then so it
was right when I met Mr exping who
machismo over there so I mean it's 100%
going to be me yeah well well you don't
know there yet we don't know and it's
going to be embarrassing and [__]
know know dude it has nothing do with he
wouldn't do that you should know him
dude you should know he would do that
I'm not going to embarrass you I promise
uh my what he's a bad friend oh yeah
yeah for not knowing that and not saying
H sure right right not just the double
do yeah okay so I had like you know how
like at that age he [__] his pants
anyway
next at that
age he [__] his pants and came in the
same time anyway next and fell in a
plate of okay so next one the biggest
plate of pasta you know
um you know how when you're at that age
you have a girlfriend but it's like you
ask them do you want to go out with me
and all that happens is you talk to them
less than you did before Rebecca angine
okay so this was Sarah Hudson my
girlfriend remember her so Sarah I know
you're watching because you're probably
a big fan of the show Rea too and blah
blah blah and so Sarah I'm sure you
remember this happened on my I don't
know if it was my birthday or just out
of the blue maybe she wrote me a
note uh and I was I was so excited to
read it that I waited until I got home
to read it okay I didn't even read it
wow no wait no hold on the cute meter is
crazy exploding I was so so into her it
was like I would I would this is
adorable in Home Room class when
everybody would read or nap or whatever
I don't remember I would go out into the
hallway and make an excuse just just
because I thought maybe Sarah would walk
by bro and she would pretty often but
like that's it's not is crazier even
admitting
this I was [__] 10 it's
embarrassing uh okay but so I get the
note okay and I and it's like the M it's
what this girl the one who just called
it's what she wants more than anything
from her boyfriend right it's like the
most mushy overthe top stickers on it
like stickers on it flowery pink writing
you know with big bubbly n's and B's and
[__] all the letter okay so and it's
just like it's not a poem but it's very
poetic and like so over the moon sweet
okay about how like my eyes light up in
the Stars whatever the [__] her
fingers did the dancing yeah her fingers
totally did the dancing right on a piece
of paper yeah with a pen
mhm oh danti dancing that weekend it was
on a Friday whatever that weekend
obviously because I'm 10 I'm spending
most of my time with like either my
friends during the day or at night with
Mom
and maybe dad and like we would watch
movies and the movie that we watched on
a randomly we decided to put on you and
Mom and Dad yeah or I think it was just
me and mom actually uh was uh miv Ryan
my God my Father the Hero is that the
Gerard deard movie Gerard de okay Gerard
deard don't watch that movie okay
because it's not good at all but I
[__] was loving it it was like
hilarious in retrospect it's totally not
[__] hilarious at all uh if you watch
it for 10 minutes you'll know what I
mean but I'll spare you watch it t
there's a scene in the movie where the
daughter dra deu and her daughter are on
vacation right they everybody mistakes
them for a couple and it's really
embarrassing for them he's French right
it's something yeah I don't even know
yeah right and but she actually falls
for like it's like this Resort place she
falls for one of the guys that works at
the resort right right right and there's
this dramatic moment where like they're
going to split and maybe not going to
work out and she I don't remember if
it's she or he she from below he's
sticking out a window listening to her
make her case right and she just word
for word oh wow her speech is exactly
what Sarah Hudson wrote in her not I
can't believe I didn't see this coming
okay so my f she first of all and then
Chris bucker [__] his pants and yeah
exactly and fell in a PL of pasta and
dude it was Al of all
movies of all movies
of of all movies to rip off with for a
love letter yeah not like Siro de bers
well that would be completely I mean you
would know immediately what the [__] is
this right roxan but okay so it's the
cheesiest [__] ever now in my mind but
I'm So Into Sarah I don't even call her
out on it when it happened I knew and I
was like that's so that's such [__]
but I didn't want to like how does this
story have to do with one of
us one of us he one of us and me one of
were competing for her love in fifth
grade oh I remember that so it's amazing
we're still friends it's amazing we're
still friends it really is honestly um
no but Sarah Hudson I've called you out
now the world knows you stole a
monologue from the movie My Father the
Hero and I knew I didn't I don't really
know I don't only know I knew all along
wait hold on you haven't even mentioned
me yet I know the I was well he forced
the issue the end was going to involve
how there was a triangle between me and
you and her yeah I forgot about that
love triangle well now that I'm thinking
about I'm getting pretty mad again uh
but yeah that's so anyway you really got
played I got played hard dude yeah wow
uh anyway bad dumb boyfriend possibly a
bad boyfriend but what do you do about
it you got to get over it if you're
going to date this guy that's what he's
like and now you know that so either
you're okay with it and you stay with
them or you're not and you leave them
it's not there's no reason to be upset
about it it's just he's telling you who
he is you're either okay with it or not
I'm still laughing at the plate of pasta
yeah
yeah all
[Laughter]
right Matt Clayton out of Las Vegas Mark
wallberg so uh big fan of the show but I
got a quick question for you um I'm told
on a daily basis that I look like Mark
wal of course you do of course you are
like from the time I was inth grade I
hear it all the time it's gotten worse
as I've gotten older and it's not like
it's an insult it's kind of a compliment
good looking guy but it gets kind of
obnoxious so what can I tell people to
not sound so much like a dick MH but
basically [__] off oh it's very simple
oh [__] well I didn't see the end of it
play Play It Again Play you got to play
it again for Chris the end of it just
the end of it most the [__] there is
look
thanks wow dude that's the
[__] is so much like Mark trying to be
like Mark wallberg yeah right you're
kind of leaning into it yeah you lean
into it dude he's got black tank top on
he doesn't want to admit it but you're
leaning into it that's F you are dude
but here's the thing tell people you are
him I am Mark wahr yeah oh you man you
look so much like Mark W oh that's cuz I
am that's cuz I am yeah maybe do the
voice maybe you don't even have to the
voice do voice nobody's nobody would
think oh that's not his voice though
nobody's smart that's the other thing to
remember that's nobody is smart that is
something to keep in mind in all of your
interactions with all people for all
time people used to think that I was PG
Gasol oh yeah that's I mean that's
idiotic this guy looks like Mark
Wahlberg people be like are you PG Gasol
I'm like bro I'm 6'2 yeah yeah yeah
that's idiotic uh wow so idot don't
that's how stupid people all though they
know who p gasal is they don't know he's
610 like what they see a 6'2 guy and
think it's pool that's how dumb people
are sir are you p somebody said to me
once yeah I believe that I stood up and
I said no right right K his [__] ass
dude nice uh no but if it's possible
just tell people you are him have fun
with it yeah true but if it's your
friends I don't know dude I'm not I'm
not am I Mark wallberg well feel the
vibrations and you kiss him and then be
like come on Funky Bunch let's go wow I
mean yeah that's I guess that's an
option they like that's that must have
been mark
uh marber yeah dude I I don't that
sounds really annoying it is annoying
dude it happens a lot with me and Brad
Pit every like oh
youan it's annoying that is annoying
though dude yeah I don't I don't like
that but but you know but people just go
up and say wow you look at Mark wallberg
you you might do that to him I might do
that to him if I didn't know if you
don't know the person again say you are
him well here's the thing if I meet
somebody and they look like somebody I
don't say that the first time I'm
talking because you know they hear it
all the time it's annoying yeah and
anybody worth an ounce of anything is
going to do that for you as well do
people ever tell you you look like I
wouldn't do that until like a few
hanging outs nice okay so next
one what's up Chris and Matt thanks for
taking the call thanks for taking my
call last time about the whole body
shaving issue anyways three things on
his head my video this time is about my
wife she loves her soda she loves zero
sugar soda she loves really any soda
likes Dr Pepper the most um and she
makes a big deal you know if it's in a
bottle and it shakes a little bit cuz
she thinks you know the fizziness is
going to go away but anyways it's a it's
a it's a thing you know the problem I
have with it is that she makes a big
deal out of having her soda you know
with a meal or if we're going somewhere
she'll take it in the car with us sure
and later on I find the soda and it's
half to 3/4 full right every time uhhuh
every time mhm so she takes a couple
sips and then leaves it so really I'm
not sure what to do here it's funny not
really kind of gets on my nerves what do
you think nothing wrong with it
absolutely nothing wrong with it
absolutely nothing wrong with it in fact
it's a good thing healthier she want her
to drink the whole [__] yeah here's
the thing though I can relate to this I
almost never I love Coke I almost never
drink more than half of a Coca-Cola wow
it's just too much sugar and I don't
mean like because of health reasons I
mean like I don't want that much really
so you don't really love it then huh but
here's here's what's up I do though and
I'm always like damn we don't have any
Coke but I'll only have a few it's weird
so that is weird me and your wife are
meant to be together dude I love Coke
Calvin loves Coke dude oh got to be
careful I know dude and he'll bring it
in he'll be like Mom maybe Mom wants a
coke cuz he knows he get some sips he's
working it yeah he's working so funny
kids like that they don't know they
don't know that like we know more than
that you should be like come here Calvin
and when he gets over say
you don't realize it but you don't know
[__] okay I know what you're up to to
him and from here on out I have your
number and then go like
this Dr all of it just and then crush it
and then be like throw that away but but
before before you crush it make sure
there's a little bit left poured out
yeah and then do it yeah yeah um no but
uh I love Coca-Cola I absolutely love
Coca-Cola I haven't had dude I love Coke
I've haven't had Coca-Cola in years now
I'm great here's something I Haven even
even longer I loved Coke I'm great and
for I would say
maybe maybe five whole years actually I
didn't have any soda or any sugar oh
really and when I started when I had my
first few cooks I that when I started
eating sugar I was repulsed by it oh
really so you might remember loving it
because I just kept doing it like a
habit like why do people start smoking
same [__] you know weird uh uh because I
still remembered my mind smoking makes
more sense though to me take a bre
addicted to this [__] man no no no I
know I'm just saying to get back into it
make sense you take a break I got to
[__] take a a drag I think in my mind
I still remember the Nostalgia of it
you're like I'll get back into it no
it's not Nostalgia it's like the it's
nostal the wi for I don't know F I don't
[__] know it doesn't matter but it
could be Nostalgia but so the point is
lawyer a
lawyer the the people versus Nostalgia
the people versus Coca-Cola's Nostalgia
dude um
I I think
that uh Coke is great I have no idea
what the question was about and that's
all I'm saying I I don't remember the Dr
Pepper not oh yeah it's all good dude
you got a bro come on you got good you
got a good life dude it it's it's better
she doesn't drink it it's 100% it's also
those first two sips are are the best
anyway yeah I mean ohai so much it's all
downhill from the Second Step second sip
yeah yeah yeah so so she's doing good
you need to respect you need to let you
know you got it you got a good dude M
you know you got a good life so go kiss
your wife and take some of the things
off and get on your knees and thank her
for the great life she's given imagine
she did that he did that he should I
want to thank you so much for the great
life you give thank you so much you
could drink as much coke as you want Dr
pepp Dr Pepper is didn't listen at all
the that's more of my
concern shitty taste people who like Dr
Pepper will go to war for Dr Pepper you
understand that it's crazy bro the two
of them are Dr Pepper and and diet coke
diet coke diet coke people are wild is
the worst tastes like it tastes like a a
factory it tastes like a factory if you
turns it into liquid dude it really does
yeah it tastes like a factory it really
does it tastes like something that is
like built yeah and and Dr Pepper tastes
way too
sweet God it's hard if remember what a
peer taste hey how about this what is
that taste I think it I think it's pepp
I think it's cinnamon pepper that's what
it's supposed to be yeah I think right
it's like big red bubblegum oh really
Pepper Dr Pepper is like a cinnamon
thing isn't it I I don't think so it's
so bad what is it that's a good question
actually what the [__] is seething how
he said it I don't think so the whole
thing is like there's 23 flavors of Dr
Pepper ew yeah that's not a good thing
no there you go yeah what does it say
plum Pepper Root Beer rum raspberry the
[__] hell prun orange nutmeg molasses
I taste yeah it does taste like molasses
I guess black Licor that tastes as well
that's disgusting carrot bro dude oh
come on they're just rum they're just
throwing everything in the in this black
licorish yuck bro nutmeg dude
so that's why it says 23 on it 23
flavors not because of Michael Jordan I
thought Michael Jordan always wait Dr
Pepper has 23 on it some look at the can
oh that's weird wow I this is blowing my
mind I have I've never known this yeah
that's why there's always question marks
following it see I'm G to I'm going to
sue I'm going to sue
them so I guess they don't they don't
tell us what it all is though they just
did didn't they nah because they
wouldn't tell us because then we would
just make it and not everybody just
brewing what you doing make Dr Pepper
I'm I got I got to go get 47 fruits I'm
going what are you doing make a Dr
Pepper in a produce section would you
guys have a rum just buy one you know
yeah you put I put too I put too much
[__] rum in it um what the [__] a
drink too much Dr Pepper pass out all
right all next
one what's up Matt and Chris uh Tom here
calling from New York hey you don't I'm
just gonna keep that clock dude it's
crazy why do people have that insecure
cat clock I is that a Cheshire Cat what
is that what what the [__] bro how does
a let me ask you whatever it is dude how
does a
[__] cat clock like that pop off like
you don't walk into a [__] if you
never seen that before you walk into
somebody's house you see that clock you
go I got to get that yeah
no one knows how did that clock pop the
[__] off that's it's a really good
question crazy bro it's a really good
question I would love to know the answer
but I bet no one knows here it
is smashed you to smithin what is it
tell Kit Kat clock it's been around for
over 80 years yeah I know it's old but
why though why does somebody have it in
2023 maybe he's going to tell us it's
just Americana from the but that's come
on bro no you know what it's like it's
like the the swirly blue white and red
things outside of Barber Shop it's like
every barber shop has to have them
people just do what other people do with
you but barber shop at least a place
that you would see that this is like in
everybody's [__] house sometimes it's
so dumb it's such a bad clock it's so
bad bro yeah it's crazy hey
hey with the tail wagon and [__] you
know it might be cool to have like an
old antique one but this looks like he
just bought it at Target bro he got it
online you got it online at [__]
cvs.com dude kit at KitKat cat.com or
whatever buying tweezers different sizes
of tweezers and then he saw that was
like I'll throw that in there too wait a
minute it was like $1.99 yeah if that
that clock is not 11.99 I'll honestly
cut off one of my nuts all right next
let's see what's up all right let's see
sweet because I've done this like 20
times what do you guys think about when
people like touch you or nudge you or
like even hit you uh while they're
talking to you to ensure that like
you're still listening to them um I do
everything I can to let the other person
know that I'm still listening to them
and they still will like touch me as
they're talking to me um this is very
annoying to me makes me blood curling
mad do you have any advice on what to
say uh or like a spin move to do um to
in a funny way get the person to uh stop
touching me while they're talking to me
would be great thanks guys one of those
I know you can do get rid of that clock
that's my advice but that's one of those
things that is ingrained people yeah
they don't I got this I got in this
conversation today really IAL yeah dude
I do golden AR Brendon
sha I'm like bro that's so annoying he's
also so big I'm like this you know what
I notice it's usually big men that do
that find me a woman that does that
there's no woman that does that Dean Del
does it all the time too and he's not a
woman I know okay so I'm saying it's
such a me guy thing to do first of all
but like I find that only big the I the
the person I'm thinking of that does it
the most that I is enormous it's so
brendon's huge it's so annoying dude and
I say to him I'm like bro why do you do
that what does he say he says oh man I
don't know it's just how I show love I
don't know I'm just talking to you I
like you don't do it to Eric on the
other side love
ER you know that's how you know no but
like what is that's not I agree with
this guy dude stop my stories are so
dope that I don't have to touch you yeah
have the confidence here's here's the
deal here's what you should say and then
it was to Target don't do that no I know
it's boring oh hey and that's then I
bought the thing at Target okay but
you're doing it and I'm getting
triggered but it's a I'm doing it I know
but I'm still getting triggered do you
know what I mean and then you know what
Mom
said it's like they think you're going
to turn away or I he my mom said this
hey it's just it it why are you I know
they don't it's like they don't think
about it but like think it all the way
through why are you touching and and
like it's like a aggressive too I don't
like it not about bad dude so what you
do is when I'm assuming there's a friend
of his that does it all the time and
starting to bother
him say learn how like you know that
thing you get somebody's in arm bar you
know uhhuh uh then do learn how to do a
swift arm bar or throw do a throw and
then when he's like ah say say why you
hitting me why you hitting me I'm
listening I'm listening why you hitting
me and then maybe they'll answer you or
scream out when they touch you like that
scream out
assault yeah that that would be good as
well it's it's annoying hey oh you're
boring huh you could do like that you're
boring huh because you think that I'm
going to turn away because your stories
are so boring that's why it touching me
so you think boring people do it that's
what you're saying no I don't think
boring people do it but my point is your
story should be so good that it should
just completely immobilize me into well
and then what but some people are doing
it to be like chummy and like Yeah and I
don't like those that's even worse like
yeah you're not going to force
friendship on me we're we're we're
already friends friendship needs to be
we're already as much friends as we're
going to be you doing that is not going
to link us y further mhm but yeah just
be like honestly the thing to do in all
honesty is in the moment when he does it
just be like dude what what wait hang on
why you why do you do that oh and don't
be like a dick about it don't be
confition but be curious and be clear
that you're curious get get you can do
this with an oops button at crystal.com
or you can just get anything just
anytime they do it just whatever it is
you don't need to be an oops button but
oh you touch me and how how long do how
annoying it is right but then they'll be
like what are you doing yeah you be like
every time you touch me I do it just so
you know I want you to know how many
times it happen I guess what I'm asking
is you don't explain it you just start
doing it yeah or you can like bouncers
when people walk in the club get one of
those things with with with the one two
three four yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
good too a click a clicking counter MH
okay all right next
one hey guys my name is liby I was on
episode 60 uh people who are too
friendly in the gym and I actually have
an update for on that that worker quit
about a month after I sent in that video
so it's not a problem anymore but my
current problem is with my job I'm a
wedding videographer a couple of months
ago I worked with a very difficult
photographer and she just posted those
photos from that wedding she did not tag
me in anything she tagged a couple of
the vendors but not me and this is a big
issue for me because since she was so in
experienced uh I ended up posing about
90% of those photos that she just posted
oh wow and I would like credit when I
posted my highlight film from that day I
tagged her so I just need to know what
to do do I call her out do I message her
what do I do well if she's unexperienced
then if she's inexperienced maybe that's
part of it yeah honestly just reach out
and be like hey can you don't don't even
allude to the fact that she didn't do it
just be like hey I saw the the post
would you mind tagging me it's really
helpful for business for me that's good
that's it that's good advice you don't
have to be like hey I noticed you didn't
or like hey why didn't you none of that
matters because the truth is you don't
give a [__] about this person right
right right all you give a [__] about is
her tagging you what does it mean that
she was posing the pictures what does
that mean I'm just going to I'm just
going to breathe through this I'm pissed
why you mad at me because it's so
obvious well I don't know what that
means she's a videographer the other
person's a photographer for those photos
at weddings and also other events you
pose the people in the pictures so that
they come out better she's saying she
did this woman's job for her and
obviously she should be tagged anyway
but she went above and beyond for this
inexperienced photographer and so she
thinks it's like a bigger slap in the
face but honestly don't even think of it
that way just be like don't be mad I
said that so but don't think of it like
she did it on purpose you're you said
yourself she's inexperienced so hold on
a second though she is UPS why why okay
not even Devil's Advocate I'm dumb why
would she tag
her because she as as this woman very
clearly said she tagged the other
vendors that they that she worked with
some of them but not all of them and not
her well but but okay so if somebody
takes a picture of the groom and the
bride and they tag the bride's dress
business but not
her I don't really see the problem in
that she wants to be tagged this is the
only problem she can be offended or as
not offended as she wants I suggest
being zero offended because Chris is
right maybe it didn't even cross her
mind right right right right right maybe
it's a thing in their industry that most
maybe it is yeah I don't know that's
what I'm saying that's what I'm assuming
but it doesn't matter because you
shouldn't let it upset you anyway all
you need is to ask her to do it and
she'll do it yeah because she even if
she was like [__] this girl I'm not
going to do that and I know I'm supposed
to but I'm not going to she would do it
after you asked and and especially if
she seemed oblivious to any potential
slight so what you want to do is just
straightforwardly ask in a nice enough
way in just a util AR in way hey can you
tag me in those I would appreciate it it
helps my business and she and she said
also that she was difficult to work with
I wonder what that
means
maybe guess probably yeah yeah that
sucks sometimes inexperienced people end
up being not just inexperienced and and
like green they end up being
disrespectful because they don't even
know the rules the ropes the way things
go it's doubly bad all right it's a it's
a it's a war out there
wow Chris getting into politics it's a
war out there
next hey Chris and Matt just killed
someone my girlfriend is pregnant and um
she is um she has become
um a monster she's upset with everything
I
do and uh I I
wonder should I put up with that for 9
months or what should I do I can't
really talk to her because she gets
upset all the
time I know you Chris
um have two kids so you probably have
some
experience this guy is a real a real
find dude hold for Humanity hold up this
guy his girlfriend's pregnant I didn't C
that part the first part I didn't get
she's pregnant
she must be okay
yeah
dude okay hold up first of all let me
just get this out of the way if it's the
first three
months buckle up bro the second that
first trimester ends is way better okay
my girlfriend hates everything I do and
then the way he did it unbelievable
killed her just straight up already
killed her yeah but also lizard he's a
lizard right he's a lizard personified
in in person in human form right lizard
person right so uh that guy is he
[__] with us I mean no I don't think
so I mean he might have been realizing
that's funny to do but he's asking for
real bro my girlfriend what he said my
girlfriend's pregnant how do I deal with
it for nine months it's basically is she
no he's saying she's right now a monster
and what does he do here's the thing wow
dude nobody ever talks about how hard it
is for guys when the girls are prant you
know that was going to be bad because
that's all anyone ever says so also it's
only 9 months dude at the end you have a
kid and then everything kind of gets
back to normal in terms of how people
behave right there's postpartum okay
well anyway like you must have known
this was possible it's a hormonal thing
just think of it that way it's not even
her you got to just kind of sit through
it and uh but people don't often they
don't talk about how hard it is for the
man go in another room eat a Popsicle
watch Lifeline watch something else if
you've watched every episode of Lifeline
yeah watch congratulations you know then
just
like eat your yellow ice pop like you're
seven years old dude that ice pop sucks
that would looked so [__] not good
yeah remember the remember the Frozen
the lemon ones that would in high school
what the [__] were they they were like
lemonade no but it was it was like the
freeze what the hell oh they were all
different colors no no no they were
yellow they were only yellow were they
long like dicks or were they like fatter
with ridges two dicks stuck together
oh yeah I remember those yeah two
popsicle sticks yeah pull them apart
they would sometimes not split right
lemon freezer something what the hell
were they called those were good no no
and I liked fudge sickles too no that's
totally different I know that's whyles
were also not so good no those were
great you like fud sickles they're all
right bro they're good
dude creamsicles are that's I dude we've
been over this I don't want creaming
anything that that look what's that
yellow one the dick one
the the middle dick one the dick one the
only yellow dick one okay well all
yellow four yellow ones looking like
yellow dicks all right
that I used to meet you too tropical
yeah I I think that's what the guy was
eating no that's not what I was no it's
what that guy was eating I said I'll
tell you what I tell you what they
weren't two of them in it it was only
one it was one but it was a thick one it
was like that that white and red that's
what I remember yeah that's what Mom lik
there you go it looked like that Mom
liked them yeah f with The Ridges but
but dude but that was n the lemon one
that's not the lemon one and and and a
mom didn't like the lemon ones right
okay so don't say mom like
them lemon ice
popsicles uh oh I see what you're saying
I know Mom did like a version of this
yeah she did didn't she dude these are
trash these are all trash bro the only
thing that's good the only that's good
is a fudge cicle popsicles are [__]
trash I couldn't agree more man if
you're going to have something Frozen a
Frozen treat ice cream sandwiches just
regular ice cream dude it's crazy it is
how could you if you're an adult how
could you want a popsicle it's nut when
Calvin says even when Calvin's [__]
four kind a popsicle I go that's you you
don't really know about life yet dude
when somebody's 50 and they're like will
you grabb me a popsicle dude that is
UN that's unbelievable bro this guy it's
crazy killed his spouse so he's clearly
in an altered mental state maybe we can
cut him some slack but in general we
can't
in general that is a disgusting thing to
do as an adult yeah don't be talking
about how your wife thinks nothing
you're doing is Right while you're
sucking a popsicle bro a yellow one it's
yeah dude flavor could be that didn't
even look like lemon dude H fud cicle
would be okay like even if it was
raspberry I get it but a [__] lemon
[__] just it might have been cream
something you know what it doesn't
matter what it it doesn't matter even if
he was doing it for a joke and I'll tell
you why
he still had the Popsicles which means
that they're in his house did not go buy
them for the right right right even if
he's kidding so that's Bonkers yeah to
have one of those in your freezer is
just crazy unless you already have kids
but guess what he doesn't and we know
that because of what he said on the
video exactly I've never I haven't had a
popsicle why would you have a popsicle
in bro it's got to be I probably had
last time I had pops was like when I was
like 14 I was like this still sucks yeah
good I'm glad you agree with that dude
they're ter you be the kind of guy
that's like nah but I love popsicles no
popsicles are terrible dud you like
cupcakes not really nah it's
a you like
cake it depend I like ice cream cake ice
creake but that's not cake no I don't I
like ice cream you like ice cream that's
the ice cream is doing the heavy lifting
ice cream cake though is so good like a
good Carell cake yes no yeah I
understand that but that's not cake
though I know I'm just saying but the
ice cream is doing the heavy lifting is
what I'm saying sure it's like it's like
you know what I'm saying a good ice
cream cake what I'm saying is a good ice
cream cake is better than any ice cream
to me oh that's what you're saying that
wasn't what you were saying but that's
what you're saying yeah like the car the
classic caral is pretty crazy bro is the
is like my favorite pry to Carell ice
cream cake for every meal I would do it
that's a pretty crazy thing to say you
said two crazy things that it's better
than ice cream and that you would eat at
every meal it's absolutely Bonkers and I
love ice cream and I still think that is
even and there's the third czyy thing I
love ice cream
yeah you do I I I really like chocolate
chip cookies love ice cream like
brownies the not the Gourmet ones
brownies are tricky you got to bres are
tricky agree um and then other dessert
stuff I like that are are like you love
ice cream sandwiches well cookies and
ice cream that's what that is pretty
much yeah true you know so forget it
dude you go to the ones of Trader Joe's
o Chef kiss I too people go yo hey dude
I got a funny joke hey I got a funny
joke dude imagine eating EA one ice
cream
sandwich so stupid dude yeah right bro
are you kidding me yeah oh man you know
who has the good they're so good mhm
tilamook no have you had one dude wait
Ice Cream Sandwich yeah oh I didn't know
they had ice cream sandwiches I thought
you meant tillamuk ice cream I'm not
really a huge fan of that it's kind of
[__] the [__] ice cream sandwi Uncle
Mike lik oh no that's McConnell's never
mind go ahead M ice cream sandwiches
dude really cuz you said it he goes yes
yeah they're a thing like they're crazy
good really I I don't know if I'd like
it man I'm telling you you know what I
had the other day though you like it you
know what I had the other let's look at
the tilamook ones you know what I had
the you told me about the tilamook ones
before you know I had the other day
Mexican food that you would have liked
oh yeah it's
downtown oh sonville oh yeah yeah good
right I knew you'd like it dude I know
my brother yo and you liked it too right
and it's authentic isn't it yes okay I
lik it oh you liked it oh I liked it a
lot but I don't like authentic Mexican
[__] so why'd you like it I don't know
but I took a bite and I was like this is
authentic and I think he likes it turn
so Italian when
you all right look so good vanilla bean
bro is so good The Salted Caramel so
good there's a chocolate one I think so
good Bam Bam Bam bing bang Bo this looks
like they tried to do a little different
with it they did though and they
succeeded oh they succeeded yeah they
succeeded totally sued suceeded from the
United States um I don't caramel get out
of here right I agree but they're good
car I don't know what to do unless
you're in get wait you're you're in
sckers all right I'll allow it where
else are you get out of here can only be
Italian talking about food dude I I no
yo caramel for some reason hey dude you
come in my doorstep with caramel get out
of here you couple up with some nice
nuts and a [__] chocolate covered
[__] and you're in that brown bag with
the [__] blue letters all right I'll
allow it dude
absolutely shouting dude you are being
so loud I can't even believe it caramel
sucks dude and I will tell you right now
you put that on my ice cream dude get
the [__] out of here hey hey you make it
on a nice you know like a dicksize
[__] you know uh chocolate with the
drizzle and then you you roll it up in a
in a brown little with the [__] blue
lettuce all right all right now we're
talking I swear to god dude the mini
ones get out of here I want a whole one
dude like mini [__] Milky Ways
Snickers or all that [__] oh get out hey
hey hey get out of here give me the
whole fun one give me a whole I don't
want the fun size no I don't want the
fun size I want the big dick king
size hey hey hey Fun Size get the
[__] Fun Size out of here get the
[__] Fun Size out of here what am I
[__] six yeah well it's four sixy old
so makes sense uh bad
uh
dude dude if you put caramel on ice
cream honestly that's crazy I'll arrest
you citizens
[Music]
arrest I go to someone in a
diner come here turn around I'm making a
citizen's arrest put put caramel and ice
cream come on call the
cops [__] oh [__] man God we're good why
it got hot let me tell you right now why
this podcast is it's so good yeah we
have such a good
rapport sometimes I'm like I look at the
views and I don't do it much and I'm
just like there's a whole slew of people
missing out yeah I mean we get a lot of
people to watch no no no no no it's
great but I'm like man yeah well it
should obviously be more yeah it should
be 3 million people yeah yeah yeah yeah
I don't get it I don't get it your job
dude is to let people know about this
podcast yeah what what are you guys
doing it's just CRA what are you guys
doing tell everyone like your life
depends on it why cuz why would you not
do that it's happiness dude it's
happiness in a podcast it's happiness in
a podcast you know I'm tired man I'm so
tired the screaming thing really made me
tired it made me tired I wasn't even
doing it so look after this go get my
special grower dieet at chia.com almost
r at christ.com or sign up oh you know
what you want more you want more
Lifeline you want more Lifeline go to
Lifeline luxury patreon.com
Lifeline luxury you get them all we [__]
we do it we do it up right got my uh new
podcast coming out soon the private
record you want to be on it you got a
good story you got a crazy story you
want to share with the world submit
yourself as a potential guest at the
private.com do it do it now come be
famous come be famous get on the show
and be really really famous uh and
obviously you got uh question or you got
advice that you want to seek on this
show submit all the info below uh keep
him Comming we get so many good videos
from you guys and honestly even if we
don't pick it we appreciate it so much
yeah we do we do we do you guys [__]
are amazing and we love you uh you want
uh the merch do you want the merch or do
you not want the merch you want the
merch go buy the merch lifel merch.com
you really only drank half at that huh
yeah see I know that's I'm saying it's
the truth being
real
bye
hello
hello hello please
hello hello